Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Du, hier kommt gerade eine Meldung rein. Kuh stirbt nach Cyberattacke auf Melkroboter.
Tim, über sowas macht man keine
Witze. Das war bestimmt ein hoher finanzieller Schaden für den Bauern.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 498 vom 15. August 2024.
Und passt auf eure Kühe auf.
Ja, aber das war bestimmt, Kühe gehören ja heute gar keinen Bauern mehr.
Kühe gehören Agrarunternehmen. Einem Agrarkonzern.
Oder?
Aber Bauern, Agrarkonzern.
Nee, der Bauer gehört dem Agrarkonzern.
Ich weiß nicht, warum du da so wenig Mitgefühl hast. Ich habe das ja nur vermeldet.
Also da war eine Cyberattacke, eine Ransomware-Attacke auf so einen Windows-Computer.
Ja, ist ein Produktionsmittel bei draufgegangen.
Und dann hat der Bauer einfach zu wenig Logbuch-Netzpolitik gehört,
wie das bei den meisten Bauern übrigens der Fall ist.
Ja, bemängeln wir.
Das ist in der Tat ein echtes Problem.
Und weil er die Sendung nicht gehört hat über Ransomware, hat er sich gedacht,
was kann mir schon passieren?
So, und dann hat er halt seine Lösegeldforderung bekommen, die wollte er dann
nicht zahlen und dann kam er aber nicht mehr an die Daten ran von der Kuh.
Und dieser Melkroboter, der speichert halt auch so die ganzen Vitalitätsdaten
und dann ist ihm halt die Kuh, naja.
Meinst du Vitaldaten oder Vitalitätsdaten?
Also die Vitalität einer Kuh, glaube ich, kann der Bauer auch so einschätzen.
Gut, dann halt die Vitaldaten, was auch immer, auf jeden Fall.
Durch den Datenverlust war dann sozusagen… Aber welche Inkubation ist.
Denn verloren gegangen?
Die Kuh war irgendwie, was war mit der Kuh, die war irgendwie,
sollte einen Kalb bekommen, aber der Landwirt wusste nicht, wann die Befruchtung
stattgefunden hat und so weiter und dann ein totes Kalb im Mutterleib und dann
musste die eingeschläfert werden.
So kam es, weil Datenverlust drohte und nicht nur drohte sondern stattfand und
dann wurde der halt nicht,
Antivirusprogramm hat er auch gehabt, hat nichts genutzt,
aber halt kein Backup und das ist halt so ein bisschen ein Problem und das tut
uns natürlich jetzt leid für die Kuh und das Kalb aber kein.
Backup kein Mitleid Hahaha.
Kommen wir zum Ich hab dir gesagt.
Wir können keine Witze über die tote Kuh machen Ja.
Du hast Witze über die tote Kuh gemacht Ich hab hier nur Fakten geliefert Das
ist ja überhaupt meine Aufgabe Scherzbold,
Ihr seht schon, wir sind mit voller Seriosität hier am Start und mit der gleichen,
Zuneigung und Intensität schauen wir auch auf euer Feedback und,
das Gute ist, dass jetzt auch unsere Witze erklärt werden, die wir nicht bereit
waren zu erklären wie zum Beispiel den Witz der verborgen war im Titel der letzten Sendung.
Real men use it after free.
Genau, after free, Klammer auf, Klammer zu.
Und das Erstaunliche ist, dass wenn man das halt so in die heutigen allwissenden
Müllhalden, also in unsere, nie passte dieser Begriff besser.
Ich hab den ja eigentlich immer für die Wikipedia ins Feld gezogen und mittlerweile.
Aber ist das nicht eher so eine müllwissende Allhalde?
Also auf jeden Fall passt allwissende Müllhalde noch besser auf LLMs,
als es auf die Wikipedia passt.
Okay, ja.
Also das war ja eigentlich nur so ein Pun, weil ich schon ähm,
Ich finde das überhaupt interessant. Jetzt schauen wir schon langsam auf die
Ära der Wikipedia zurück.
Nicht, dass die jetzt komplett beendet ist, aber ich würde sagen,
wir haben ihr Wachstum gesehen und ihre Präsenz und ihre Bedeutung,
die sie ja auch nach wie vor hat.
Aber derzeit ist das so ein wenig überschattet durch diese neuen,
in Anführungsstrichen, Intelligenzen, die jetzt so besserwisserisch daherkommen
und sich zur Not halt irgendwas auch so einfach nur so aus der Nase ziehen.
Während du bei der Wikipedia halt schon richtig Aufwand treiben musst,
um eine Falschinformation zu verbreiten.
Das könnte der Wikipedia in gewisser Hinsicht sogar zuträglich sein.
Weil es jetzt irgendwie einfacher ist, die Lügen einfach irgendwo ins Internet
zu stellen und dann werden sie da automatisch abgegrast und ohne direkte Quellenverweise
einfach so reproduziert.
Da musst du nicht mehr den großen Aufwand machen und dich mit der Wikipedia-Community
rumschlagen, die dann immer alles löscht und korrigiert und besser weiß und so.
Also insofern, allwissende Müllhalde,
ich würde fast sagen, kann man jetzt schon auf Chat, GPT und Co.
Weiterreichen. Aber bei solchen Sachen wie, erklär mir mal diesen Witz der letzten
Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Folge, also den Titel, wenn es ums Programmieren geht,
da muss man auch irgendwie nicht viel Kontext liefern.
Also da reicht es wirklich, Real Man, use it after free, erklär mal und dann
kommt raus und das hat in diesem Fall Chaosdeckel für uns ins Internet eingegeben, vielen Dank dafür.
Ich vermute, das hat er gecopypastet, der Deckel.
Achso, eingegeben, die Frage eingegeben in die Albitum-Müllhalle.
Ja, das ist ja auch eine Leistung dann.
Ins Internet rein.
Wir haben da keine Zeit für gehabt und diese Transferleistung hat er also verbracht.
Das wird ja auch an der Schule immer gefordert, dass die Kinder Transferleistungen erbringen.
Also unsere Sachen in Chat-GPT werfen.
Und das Ergebnis auch wieder in unsere Kommentare einstellen.
Das ist ein Doppeltransfer. Das funktioniert auch.
Es hat sich danach auch jemand bedankt dafür, dass das getan wurde,
weil nur deshalb ist in die Kommentare gegangen, um genau diese Erklärung zu finden.
So und jetzt lese ich sie auch vor. Der Witz, Real Man Uses After Free,
Klammer auf Klammer zu, bezieht sich auf die Programmierung in C oder C++,
insbesondere auf den Umgang mit Speicherverwaltung.
In diesen Programmiersprachen wird der Speicher explizit vom Programmierer verwaltet.
Dazu gehören Funktionen wie mAlloc, um Speicher zuzuweisen und free,
um diesen Speicher wieder freizugeben.
Der Witz spielt darauf an, dass es sehr riskant und unsicher ist,
auf Speicher zuzugreifen, nachdem er mit free freigegeben wurde.
Wenn ein Programm versucht, auf freigegebenen Speicher zuzugreifen,
dieser sogenannte Use-after-free,
kann dies zu unvorhersehbarem Verhalten, Abstürzen oder Sicherheitslücken führen,
weil der Speicher unter Umständen eben schon wieder von anderen Teilen des Programms genutzt wird.
Der Humor liegt darin, dass nur ein sehr waghalsiger oder in Anführungsstrichen
echter Mann in Anspielung auf die Stereotype Vorstellung von Männlichkeit solch
riskantes und potenziell katastrophales Programmierverhalten an den Tag legen würde.
Zusammengefasst, der Witz ist eine ironische Anspielung auf schlechte und gefährliche
Programmierpraktiken, die vermieden werden sollten.
Und natürlich auch auf männliches Verhalten, was auch vermieden werden sollte.
Das muss man nochmal dazu sagen.
Ja, also das hätte man jetzt besser kaum erklären können. Und man sieht,
diese LLMs sind super praktisch, wenn es um Programmieren geht.
Weil da gibt es irgendwie am meisten drüber zu lesen. Alles andere, schwierig.
Aber es ist schon, muss man mal sagen, schon, also das ist ja wahrscheinlich,
wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht, Ein neuer Witz, den es so noch nicht gab.
Was?
Real Men Use It After Free? Hat das schon mal jemand ins Internet geschrieben?
Ach, du meinst, du hast das erfunden?
Also ich hab ihn auf jeden Fall irgendwo, der kam ja eigentlich Achso.
Kam dir so.
Ja, den hab ich so Real Men Use It After Free, mal gucken.
Also das kam dann zumindest so aus der Pistole geschossen, dass ich das Gefühl
habe, du hast das schon 20 Mal erzählt.
In Anzeichen Google finde ich nur links zu uns. Das ist ein genuiner Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Witz.
Ein echter Linus sozusagen.
Oh, doch, nee, hierbei. Nee, doch, das ist tatsächlich ein echter Neumann. Er ist ein eigener Witz.
Also den finde ich nicht.
Ein echter Neumann. Den könnt ihr euch jetzt zu Hause ausdrucken oder an die Wand hängen.
Oder ihr used einfach ein bisschen After Free.
Ich finde schon beeindruckend, dass der Witz, dass das Ding den erklären kann,
obwohl ich jetzt quasi diesen Satz nirgendwo finde, wo das Ding das vorher hätte gelernt.
Das ist also auch eine Transferleistung, die hier erbracht wurde.
Programmiersprache mit Real Men. Das ist auch eine Transferleistung.
Man muss einfach sagen, das ist eine Transferleistung.
Wir verzichten jetzt darauf, noch einen CO2-Preis draufzulegen.
Das ist auch Transferleistung.
O2, CO2.
Okay.
Ja, eine andere Transferleistung wurde nicht so geleistet im Falle von CrowdStrike,
was wir ja hier besprochen haben.
Also der Vorfall, dass ein paar Millionen Windows-Rechner die Füße hochgelegt
haben und gesagt haben, wir machen jetzt hier Strike als Crowd.
Und wir wurden dann sowohl von André als auch von Stefan in den Kommentaren
darauf hingewiesen, auf ein Detail, was wir nicht erwähnt haben,
hätten aber erwähnen können,
dass der CEO von CrowdStrike, wie heißt er nochmal?
George? George, jetzt habe ich es irgendwie gerade wieder verlegt,
wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, der war tatsächlich früher auch schon mal CTO,
also für die Technik zuständig, bei McAfee.
McAfee ist ja so eine Firma...
Die sich auch so als Antivirus-Produzent hervorgetan hat.
Und denen ist es 2010 auch schon mal gelungen, irgendwie eine größere Teilmenge
an XP-Rechnern mit einem Antivirus-Update zu bringen.
Ganz kurz, ich weiß nicht, ob du das gerade richtig gesagt hast,
also bei McAfee war er CTO.
Habe ich gesagt, ja. Ah, okay. Und bei Crossfac ist er CEO und Gründer.
Also ich würde sagen, Zeit, dass der seine eigene APT-Nummer bekommt.
Was ist das?
APT? Advanced Persistent Threat.
Und wenn du jetzt so bestimmte Angreifergruppen, wenn du jetzt notorisch genug
bist, dann bist du irgendwann APT 29 oder so.
Und da würde ich sagen, dem könnte man jetzt auf jeden Fall advanced,
persistent und eine Bedrohung.
Also ich würde vorschlagen, dass man dem mal eine Nummer jetzt zuweist.
Die werden allerdings nicht so offiziell vergeben. Das wird dann irgendwie so,
also die werden eher so ein bisschen herausgezaubert.
Aber ich denke, George Kurz könnte man jetzt langsam mal eine Nummer geben.
George Kurz, so hieß er. Dann gab es noch so diverses Feedback zu unserer Diskussion
über Silicon Valley und warum da gerade alle den Verstand verlieren.
Das sind im Wesentlichen alles Buchempfehlungen. Da wir diese Bücher nicht gelesen
haben, die dort empfohlen wurden, empfehle ich sie jetzt mal nicht,
aber ich empfehle euch einfach mal in die Kommentare zu schauen und euch die
Buchempfehlungen anzuschauen.
Vielleicht ist ja was für euch dabei.
Ansonsten wird ja auch gerade klar, da kommen wir auch gleich nochmal drauf,
dass der Verstand auch weiterhin noch nicht wiedergefunden wurde,
insbesondere von Elon Musk.
Nimmt Formen an.
Alright.
Ja, weitere Formen nimmt an. Eine rechtliche Auseinandersetzung zwischen den USA und Google.
Denn die USA haben Google verklagt und schon vor einer Woche kam eine Entscheidung raus,
also vom US-Bundesgericht, also United States District Court for the District of Columbia,
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, womit man das jetzt hier vergleichen könnte.
Das ist also auf jeden Fall ein föderales Gericht, also was quasi auf Bundesebene entscheidet.
Und ja, da wird dann halt festgestellt, dass es sich bei Google um einen Monopolisten
handelt, insbesondere im Suchbereich des Internets.
Das ist natürlich eine schockierende Feststellung.
Und ja, das ist wohl jetzt auch soweit rechtskräftig. Allerdings ist damit jetzt
noch nicht unbedingt auch eine Bestrafung oder eine Maßnahme verbunden.
Diese muss jetzt erst noch ausgeknobelt werden. Und jetzt fragen sich alle,
was denn das bedeuten kann.
Konkret wurde unter anderem, oder wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe,
vor allem die Praxis von Google moniert,
dass sie anderen Unternehmen Milliardenbeträge dafür zahlen,
dass Google als Default-Suchmaschine in Betriebssystemen voreingestellt ist,
beziehungsweise in Webbrowsern. an.
Das betrifft so klangvolle Unternehmen wie Samsung, Apple,
die das ja bei iOS gemacht haben und bei Samsung halt dann, ich weiß nicht,
wie sie ihr OS nennen, aber halt die Telefone, die sie ausliefern,
basieren zwar auf Android,
aber sie liefern ja GUI und Apps und so weiter nochmal separat aus.
Die machen da ja relativ viel dazu.
Und durch dieses Geld wird sozusagen sichergestellt, dass Google dann auch bei
einem iPhone von vornherein erstmal die Suchmaschine ist.
Also wenn du dir ein neues iPhone kaufst und das einrichtest,
dann kommt halt nicht hoch, welche Suchmaschine hätten sie denn gerne.
Wir haben hier noch Bing für sie oder was weiß ich, was es sonst noch so gibt.
Sondern Google ist halt voreingestellt und wir wissen ja, wie die Leute das
Internet benutzen, sie geben es halt in Google ein. Mhm.
Und ja, jetzt wird halt diskutiert, was könnte denn jetzt hier diese Strafe sein?
Und eine Möglichkeit wäre natürlich einfach, dieses Business zu untersagen.
Dass also Google das nicht mehr tun darf.
Und ich frage mich, was da die Folge von wäre.
Es werden übrigens auch noch andere Ideen geflotet, unter anderem auch ein Breakup
von Google, also dass man bestimmte Teile von Googles Business auslagert.
Da kam zur Sprache, dass man ja zum Beispiel Chrome oder Android auch als separates
Business behandeln könnte,
also dass man sozusagen Google zwingt, das auszulagern, sodass die wie eigene Unternehmen agieren.
Mhm.
Keine Ahnung, was sie damit bezwecken wollen.
Also ich meine, es ist natürlich klar, dass Chrome über die Welt verteilt wird,
um quasi auch Google-Dienste damit zu bevorzugen.
Also man installiert sich Chrome und natürlich ist Google die Default-Suchmaschine
mit Chrome und natürlich werden einem auch sofort tausend Google-Dienste vorgeschlagen,
die man doch unbedingt noch aktivieren sollte und hier ein Sync und dein Google-Account und so weiter.
Also es ist schon ein Login-Tool und nur deswegen existiert Chrome,
weil ansonsten verdient Chrome kein Geld für Google.
Das ist eigentlich nur das Chrome-
Google dann nichts mehr kostet für das Voreinstellen von Google.
Ja, stimmt eigentlich. Aber es ist auch geile, geile,
also mit anderen Worten, man hat sich eigentlich gewundert, warum kommt von
Google einfach ein Browser und wahrscheinlich, weil die sich gedacht haben, wenn wir,
wir können entweder für den Market Share zahlen bei Firefox oder wir nehmen.
Die Millionen, die wir da sparen und bauen einfach mal den weltweit verbreitetsten
Browser definieren das Ökosystem,
machen alle anderen kaputt und sparen die Kohle und dann müssen wir nur noch bei Apple zahlen.
Aber jetzt ist halt wirklich das ist ja, ja, ja, und bei Android ist es ja auch
so ein bisschen ähnlich.
Also auch das Android-Betriebssystem ist ja als Open Source und so weiter und dann klar,
verdienen, ich weiß es jetzt nicht genau, womit sie vielleicht noch unter Umständen
Geld verdienen, aber ich würde mal sagen, unterm Strich Android ist für Google
keine unmittelbare Cash-Cow durch das Produkt Android,
sondern es ist eine indirekte Cash-Cow,
weil sie ihre Technologien und ihre Art und Weise das Web zu präsentieren natürlich
in Android auch integriert haben,
weil natürlich da auch Browser-Dienste auf Betriebssystemebene sind etc.
Also ohne, dass wir da jetzt allzu sehr ins Detail gehen, musst du ja nur schauen,
was Google-freies Android, was dafür...
Also was da für Einschränkungen mit einhergehen, was da für Aufwand mit einhergeht,
diese Geräte Android-frei zu halten.
Das heißt, das ist schon äußerst schwierig, da ein Android-Telefon zu unterhalten
und da Google rauszukratzen.
Es geht allein schon los mit, du erinnerst dich, als es um die Corona-Warn-App
und solche Sachen ging, dass die wiederum auf irgendwie Google-Services dependete,
um diese Bluetooth-Zugriff zu haben und so.
Also das ist schon sehr, sehr tief in diesem Betriebssystem drin.
Ich glaube, das reicht als kurzes Anzeichen davon, wie schwer die da ihre Finger drin haben.
Stellt sich natürlich die Frage, was wäre denn jetzt, wenn Chrome und Android
ausgelagert werden müssten von Google? Was würde denn das überhaupt bewirken?
Womit würden die denn dann Geld verdienen? Müssten die dann Lizenzgebühren nehmen
für ihren Open-Source-Kram?
Oder da wo sie vielleicht schon welche nehmen, müssten sie das steigern,
würde das Produkt dann teurer werden, gäbe es dann Alternativen dazu.
Fühle ich mich jetzt nicht so richtig qualifiziert da eine Antwort drauf zu
geben, weil ich einfach das Geschäftsmodell an der Stelle zu wenig kenne.
Bei Chrome stellt sich halt überhaupt die Frage, wie man mit einem kostenlosen
Browser Geld verdienen möchte als eigenständiges Unternehmen.
Also verkaufen werden sie ihn nicht können.
Und natürlich könnten sie dann auch von Google für die Suchen und für die dadurch
erzeugten Werbe-Impressions auch Geld nehmen und sich das sozusagen linke Tasche,
rechte Tasche einspielen.
Ob da so viel mit gewonnen ist, schwierig. Schwierig. Aber dieser Punkt mit,
was wäre, wenn sie jetzt einfach dieses Geschäft verbieten, dass man für viel
Geld so eine Default-Einstellung macht?
Was würde denn dann passieren? Dann hätte halt im Wesentlichen erstmal Apple
und Samsung und vor allem Mozilla deutlich weniger Geld.
Und soweit ich weiß, lebt Mozilla im Wesentlichen davon.
Wenn Apple weniger Geld bekommt, ist sicherlich ein größerer Dorn in deinem Auge, Tim.
Nö, die kriegen ja noch Geld.
Es sind absurde Summen. Es sind irgendwie, ich habe jetzt leider die aktuelle
Zahl, die ist jetzt im Rahmen von anderen Gerichtsverhandlungen genannt worden,
aber es sind irgendwie so 10 Milliarden oder so pro Jahr oder 12.
Milliarden?
Ja, ja. Wir reden hier von Unmengen an Geld.
Also das ist irgendwie so 25% des Services Revenue von Apple,
was Apple in dem Services Abteilung, wo auch so Apple Music und so weiter drin ist, ausweist.
So ist nur die Kohle, die sie von Google bekommen, dafür, dass sie eben diese
Default-Einstellungen machen. Wobei man muss dazu sagen...
20 Milliarden.
20? Hast du gerade die Zahl aufgehoben?
Ja, ich hab's jetzt mal gegoogelt. Google hat Apple 20 Milliarden Dollar in
nur einem Jahr bezahlt um im gesamten Apple-Ökosystem iOS, iPadOS und macOS
die Standard-Suchmaschine zu sein.
Joa, ne?
Außerdem, 36% der durch Google auf Apple-Geräten generierten Werbeeinnahmen
sind darüber hinaus an Apple geflossen.
Das heißt, selbst Google nimmt Apple noch einen Drittel ab.
Okay, krass, aber 20 Milliarden, das da muss eine alte Frau lang für stricken.
Also ich meine, Apple wird es am Ende nicht groß das Kreuz brechen,
wenn die Einnahmen an der Stelle sinken würden.
Das wäre zwar etwas, was dann erstmal nicht mehr im Jahresergebnis oder im Quartalsergebnis
ist und dann geht mal der Aktienkurs ein bisschen runter,
Aber am Ende ist ja das nicht das,
was Apple am Leben erhält, sondern das ist irgendwie alles andere und davon
haben sie immer noch genug.
Ja, also bei Apple müssen wir uns jetzt erstmal keine Sorgen machen, ist okay.
Genau, wahrscheinlich auch nicht alle Samsung. Aber was ist jetzt mit Mozilla?
Also die eigentliche Frage, die ich mir stelle ist, ist das eigentlich ein legitimes
Geschäftsmodell für so ein Bude wie Mozilla,
quasi sich vom Internetmonopolisten mit zu ernähren?
Ist das fair? Ist das sozusagen, ja okay, dann muss Google noch etwas abgeben,
da haben wir alle was davon, aber jetzt verbietet unter Umständen das Gericht,
gerade weil Google ein Monopolist ist, dass sie das tun dürfen.
Und andererseits frage ich mich natürlich auch, warum stören die sich eigentlich
daran, dass Google das tut?
Weil wenn sie wirklich Monopolist wären und wenn sie wirklich eine monopolistische, naja, ich sag jetzt mal.
Wären im Sinne dieses Urteils, in diesem Sinne von, ihr seid ja so total übermächtig,
ihr könnt ja machen, was ihr wollt.
Normalerweise würde ich darunter verstehen, ich habe so viel Macht im Markt,
dass ich nicht Unsummen von Geld dafür ausgeben muss, um am Markt auch weiterhin
diese Rolle zu behalten.
Also die Tatsache, dass sie so viel Geld bezahlen, ja, was weiß ich,
30, 40, 50 Milliarden US-Dollar im Jahr.
Ich meine, da gibt es viele Unternehmen, die träumen davon, irgendwann mal in
einer Dekade so viel Umsatz zu machen.
Wenn sie so viel zahlen müssen, um überhaupt im Spiel zu bleiben,
wie können sie denn dann Monopolist sein?
Naja, das Ding ist ja, also das ist ja, also ja, das Ding ist glaube ich nicht,
dass sie Monopolist sind. Es ist ja nicht strafbar, Monopolist zu sein.
Es ist strafbar, diese marktbeherrschende Stellung auszunutzen.
Das heißt, im Prinzip, oder was heißt strafbar, das ist problematisch.
Und da kann ich das schon sehr gut verstehen, wenn du sagst,
okay, du hast eine marktbeherrschende Stellung, okay, kann keiner was gegen
tun. Das ist die unsichtbare Hand des Marktes.
Aber wenn du halt Milliarden dafür ausgibst, um dir die zu sichern und dann
damit Milliarden machst, das ist halt problematisch.
Aber was hindert denn Microsoft daran, die Milliarden zu bezahlen? Also tun die die?
Ja. Und ich glaube, dass die EU-Kommission sich hier nicht notwendigerweise
für Microsoft einsetzen möchte, sondern, dass man halt sagt,
naja, es können nur noch irgendwelche anderen marktbeherrschenden,
Leute überhaupt versuchen, mit dir zu konkurrieren.
Also das ist die Argumentation, ne?
Das ist nicht die EU-Kommission, du hast gerade EU-Kommission gesagt, glaube ich.
Oh, sorry. Verzeihung.
Naja, gut, aber jeder, der genug Geld hat, Also das ist ja auch eine Investition.
Genau, das ist doch die Definition von Marktverzerrung.
Nein, nein, nein, es ist nicht Monopol, wenn du viel Geld hast.
Viel Geld kannst du aus irgendwas haben.
Richtig, aber wenn du dieses Geld nutzt, um Konkurrenz zu verhindern. Es geht ja nicht darum.
Geld zu nutzen, sondern es geht darum, die Stellung im Markt als solche auszunutzen.
Ja, also etwas machen zu können, was jemand anderes nicht tun kann,
weil man diese Stellung nicht hat.
Aber Microsoft könnte das tun, auch wenn sie diese Stellung nicht haben.
Sie könnten zu Google und Samsung gehen und sagen, hör mal, wir geben euch 25
Milliarden, ab jetzt ist Bing angesagt. Und ich sag dir, wahrscheinlich würde
das noch nicht mal funktionieren.
Was ist denn jetzt, wenn Google darf jetzt nichts mehr bezahlen?
Dann sagt Google so, oh ja, oh.
Das ist ja scheiße, dann können wir nichts mehr zahlen. Sie zahlen wahrscheinlich
trotzdem noch was für die generierten, für die tatsächlich geflossenen Verbindungen
und den Anteil an dem Anzeigengeschäft,
aber Apple würde ja auch Bing gar nicht haben wollen als Default.
Ja, Apple, Apple.
Naja, das würden die User halt doof finden, weil das ja sozusagen nicht so gut funktioniert.
Also, die Argumentation, glaube ich, hier ist andersrum.
Du hast ja gesagt, Chrome und Android sind ja gar keine gewinnbringenden Geschäftsmodelle.
Offensichtlich ja schon, weil sie daraus eine marktbeherrschende Stellung bauen.
Ich glaube, das ist eher die Argumentation der Marktwächterinnen, die sich das anschauen.
Die sagen, du bist so marktbeherrschend, dass du quasi die Pfade,
die Menschen irgendwo hinführen, noch direkt gleich mitdefinierst.
Ja, aber das finde ich ja gar nicht so verwerflich, dass man das macht,
dass man Produkte auf dem Markt wird, die es einfacher machen,
das eigene Produkt zu benutzen.
Ja, aber das ist eben das, warum, also ich kann verstehen, dass du das nicht
verwerflich findest, das ist ja auch erstmal in Ordnung, aber ich versuche hier
die Argumentation näher zu bringen, warum man versucht,
als marktwach Instanz das zu verhindern.
Ja gut, aber verhindern sie jetzt am Ende etwas damit wirklich,
wenn sie diesen Deal verbieten?
Also wird Googles Marktmacht dadurch nennenswert dann eingeschränkt?
Ich habe da so ein bisschen meine Zweifel, dass das dann auch stattfinden wird.
Das ist was anderes.
Zunächst einmal geht es ja nur darum, eine Praxis potenziell eben zu penalisieren.
Ob das am Ende irgendjemandem gut tut, ob es Google überhaupt schadet oder ob
am Ende Mozilla über die Klinge springt. Das ist ja nochmal eine andere Sache.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich kann das Argument wirklich nicht ganz nachvollziehen,
weil sie müssen so viel Geld aufwenden, um im Markt zu bleiben.
Das ist für mich kein Ausnutzen einer marktbeherrschenden Stellung.
Und erinnern wir uns auch nochmal, wann es das letzte Mal so einen Fall gab.
Das war, als die USA 2001 gegen Microsoft vorgegangen ist. Und weißt du,
was da das Kernargument war?
Das Kernargument war, was erlaube Microsoft, dass ihr einen Internetbrowser,
einen Webbrowser, im Betriebssystem ausliefert. Und ich dachte mir so, Leute,
selbstverständlich liefern die jetzt einen Internetbrowser aus.
Die mögen zwar jetzt eine bessere Stellung haben, ihren Browser damit auch populärer
zu machen, aber das ist ja wohl vollkommen klar, dass jedes Betriebssystem sowas braucht.
Moment, der,
volkswirtschaftliche und gesamtgesellschaftliche Schaden, der durch die Verbreitung
des Microsoft Internet Explorers entstanden ist, der lässt sich nicht wegdiskutieren, Tim.
Das ist relativ klar. Dass das ein großer Schaden für die gesamte Welt entstanden
ist, durch das Ausnutzen einer Marktbeherrschung.
Du junger Hüpfer, hast du damals einen Netscape Navigator mal benutzt?
Ich habe einen Netscape Navigator benutzt, da war sogar ein HTML Editor mit drin.
Eine Katastrophe war das. Da hast du irgendwie dein Fenster einen Pixel größer
gemacht, dann hat er die Seite neu geladen.
Also da war der Internet Explorer wirklich ein Fortschritt.
Also der Internet Explorer habe ich, nee, das muss man wirklich sagen.
Das geht nicht. Also man will ja auch einfach, man muss ja auch überlegen,
welchen Fußabdruck man im Internet hinterlässt.
Und ob du in irgendeinem Apache oder Nginx-Blog irgendwie mit MSI 6.0,
hast du nicht gesehen, stehst, das macht einfach keinen guten Eindruck.
Das ist auch einfach kein...
Ja, also ich meine, dass das dann später ein totales Trainwreck war und man
sehr viel früher auf Qualität und Sicherheit hätte dringen müssen,
da bin ich ja ganz bei dir.
Nur ich finde immer die Argumente, die im Rahmen dieser ganzen Monopol-Auseinandersetzung
gebracht werden, die sind schwierig.
Und ich finde die auch in diesem Fall schwierig. Ich finde, es greift nicht das Problem.
Trotzdem müssen wir sie ja hier richtig wiedergeben.
Ja, versuche ich ja die ganze Zeit. Also, wenn jetzt keine Kohle mehr fließt, was macht dann Mozilla?
Von Spenden leben.
Ihre eigene Suchmaschine.
Naja, ihren eigenen Werbeladen haben sie ja jetzt schon aufgemacht.
Und den Weg finden jetzt auch nicht alle besonders gut, den Mozilla da gerade einnimmt.
Also es wird auf jeden Fall nicht einfacher für freie Lösungen hier das notwendige Funding zu bringen,
weil gerade im Bereich Webbrowser sind die Investitionen, die man einfach benötigt,
um so eine Engine sicher und modern zu halten, sind erheblich.
Und das sieht man unter anderem darin, dass eigentlich nur Apple und Google
derzeit in der Lage sind, eine volle Investition in so eine Browser-Technologie zu machen.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht zahlt Google halt auch noch die Entwicklung von Firefox
mit derzeit. Und ob das so bleiben wird, das werden wir sehen.
Also ja, auf jeden Fall droht hier potenziell ein nicht wünschenswerter Effekt
mit einer solchen Entscheidung.
Das kann schon sein, ja.
Ebenfalls ein nicht wünschenswerter Effekt droht beim BKA-Gesetz.
Das hat Nancy Faeser, also Nancy Faeser macht ja jetzt so Sachen,
sagt irgendwie so, halt mal mein Bier, ich verbiete mal eben das Kompaktmagazin
und fliegt sie natürlich mit auf die Fresse, Das Magazin erscheint jetzt unter
dem Namen Nancy mit Ä, weil man eben nicht ein Magazin verbieten kann,
sondern nur die Organisation, die es hervorbringt.
Außerdem pflegt sie gerade damit offen Nase und dieses Verbotsverfahren wurde
irgendwie quasi direkt in erster Instanz erstmal insofern.
Eingehegt, dass das Verbot erstmal ausgesetzt wurde, bis sich die Richterinnen
nochmal genau angeschaut haben. Also damit legt sie sich gerade hin.
Außerdem hat sie sich überlegt, wir können ja mal das BKA-Gesetz ändern,
um die EU-Richtlinie zum Datenaustausch zwischen Polizeibehörden umzusetzen.
Und wenn wir schon dabei sind, können wir nochmal ein paar Vorhaben mit reinschubsen,
die überhaupt nichts mit der Richtlinie zu tun haben.
Und auch nicht im Koalitionsvertrag stehen, sondern sogar den Zielen des Koalitionsvertrages widersprechen.
Ja, gute Idee.
Unter anderem haben sie sich überlegt, naja, das BKA soll doch jetzt einfach
mal in Zukunft Wohnungen ohne Wissen der Betroffenen durchsuchen können.
Und potenzielle Tatmittel können unbrauchbar gemacht werden.
Also du hast quasi eine Idee, dass die Polizei quasi in deine Wohnung eindringt,
um einen Staatstrojaner zu installieren. Das war etwas, was vorher nicht ging.
Seit 15 Jahren darf das BKA Staatstrojaner einsetzen, seit sieben Jahren darf
das jede Polizei, wird auch jede
Woche gemacht, hauptsächlich gegen Drogenhändlerinnen und Drogenhändler.
Aber man darf nicht heimlich in eine Wohnung rein, um den Trojaner zu installieren.
Das würde das Innenministerium jetzt gerne erlauben.
Im Koalitionsvertrag steht dazu, sie wollen hohe Schwellen für den Einsatz von
Staatstrojaner und ein Commitment, Sicherheitslücken zu schließen.
Bin mal gespannt.
Wie sich das damit vereinbaren lassen soll. Das ist schon ein bisschen unheimlich.
Du kannst eigentlich, bisher konntest du ja davon ausgehen, dass deine Wohnung,
naja, sagen wir mal, halbwegs sicher ist, wenn du,
also zumindest vor Zugriffen des Staates, wenn du dich entfernst,
musst du natürlich noch immer davon Sorge haben, dass irgendein Wohnungseinbruch
stattfindet oder so, aber dass dann der Staat jetzt,
quasi ermächtigt wird, in deine Wohnung
einzubrechen, um deine Geräte zu infizieren, kommt mir ein bisschen,
ein bisschen großzügig vor.
Zumal wir ja hier immer noch von
Hacking im Inland, also gegen deutsche Grundrechtsträgerinnen sprechen.
Ja, in deren Wohnung dann eingebrochen wird, um die Geräte zu infizieren.
Noch dazu, wie wollen die das Gerät denn überhaupt entsperren?
Mit anderen Worten, da geht es dann
wieder auch offenbar um irgendwelche Sicherheitslücken auf den Geräten.
Das kommt mir ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen üppig vor.
Also die Halbwertszeit für so,
bürgerrechtsorientierte Grundeinstellungen bei neuen Innenministern,
die scheint auch relativ kurz zu sein.
Ja.
Kommt dann immer mit so, ja, hier Freiheit und so weiter und dann nur nach zwei
Jahren kommt dann irgendwann so, ja, jetzt müssen wir mal die Polizeigesetze verschärfen.
Ist immer das Gleiche. Es kommt auch mit dem Job. Ja, also da muss man jetzt
nicht, also wenn du den Job hast, musst du ja jedes Mal,
jedes Mal, wenn irgendetwas passiert ist, musst du ja irgendwie darauf reagieren
können und sagen können, ja, jetzt ändern wir das, weil das ja dann quasi als
dein Versäumnis angekreidet wird und dann musst du eben auf alles Mögliche reagieren.
Das ist der Job. Also ich würde sogar...
Also ich bin da vorsichtig, zu sehr der Person den Vorwurf zu machen,
weil der Job ist eben diese Vorschläge einzubringen und letztendlich ist der
Job, diese Vorschläge abzuwehren, der von jemand anderem, Justizministerium,
Bürgerrechtsorganisation oder sonstigen.
Ein kleines Beispiel, worauf muss so eine Innenministerin reagieren?
Naja, wenn halt Bellingcat hingeht und sagt, guck mal hier, Daniela Klette im
Internet auf Facebook, haben wir mit PimEyes oder was auch immer gemacht,
dann kannst du natürlich davon ausgehen, dass als nächstes das Innenministerium
sagt, müssen wir ändern.
Und natürlich soll jetzt die biometrische Überwachung im Internet auch quasi erlaubt werden.
Und zwar nicht nur dem Bundeskriminalamt oder der Bundespolizei,
sondern auch den Landespolizeien.
Nicht nur für Terrorismus, sondern auch irgendwie für alles,
was die Schwelle von Straftaten von erheblicher Bedeutung erreicht.
Und das kann natürlich dann schon wieder alles Mögliche sein.
Drogenhandel, Diebstahl, Beihilfe zu illegalen Einreisen oder sonstigen.
Die Frage, die sich da natürlich auch stellt, ist, Moment mal,
wie wollt ihr das denn eigentlich machen?
Wie wollt ihr diese Daten erfassen?
Wollt ihr einfach auch so ein Abonnement mit PimEyes oder Clearview AI machen?
Mal schauen. Im Koalitionsvertrag steht, den Einsatz von Von biometrischer Erfassung
zu Überwachungszwecken lehnen wir ab.
Das Recht auf Anonymität sowohl
im öffentlichen Raum als auch im Internet soll gewährleistet werden.
Ja, sie nennen sie FESA anders.
Weiteres Ding, wo Polizeibehörden gerade noch durch lästige Grundrechtsbedenken eingeschränkt werden,
sind so Big-Data-Systeme, also Palantir, große Datenbanken, in denen mit automatisierter
Datenanalyse irgendwie alles mögliche Tolle herausgefunden werden soll,
vor allem neues Wissen zu erzeugen.
Die Marketing-Dinger gehen da ja bis hin zu, wir schicken den Polizeiwagen,
vorher dahin, bevor ein Verbrechen passiert oder wir bestreifen dann die Kriminalitätsschwerpunkte,
häufiger, was übrigens auch, das ist ja so die lächerlichste,
die wirklich die lächerlichste,
der lächerlichste Zirkelschluss, den du überhaupt machen kannst,
ist ja, dass du sagst, pass auf, wir machen folgendes, da draußen gibt es Kriminalität,
dann fahren wir mit Autos rum und gucken, wo wir Kriminalität sehen und dann werten wir das aus,
und da, wo wir Kriminalität mit den Autos am meisten sehen, da schicken wir die dann wieder hin.
Ja, wo siehst du denn wahrscheinlich die Kriminalität?
Wahrscheinlich da, wo du mit den Autos hinfährst. Also super.
Dass man so einen Stuss irgendwie verkaufen kann und das im Radio laut,
im Fernsehen hoch und runter gelabert wird, das ist eine Marketingleistung.
Also wenn du so einen Stoß den Leuten erklärt kriegst und die nicht drüber nachdenken,
dann bist du richtig gut.
Naja, also Hessen und Hamburg haben das schon gemacht mit Gesetzen zur automatisierten Datenanalyse,
die hat das Bundesverfassungsgericht dann auch direkt gekippt und kassiert und
deswegen will Innenministerin Faeser jetzt die Befugnis klar einführen,
rechtssicher für alle Polizeien von Bund und Ländern.
Auch das hat natürlich der Koalitionsvertrag so nicht vorgesehen.
Eine tolle Einschränkung wieder auf Straftaten von erheblicher Bedeutung.
Und wer es umsetzt, ist noch nicht klar.
Entweder soll das BKA die selber entwickeln oder als kommerzielle Lösung beschaffen.
Also bei Palantir kaufen, Kosten von 14,3 Millionen Euro sind vorgesehen.
Müssen wir mal gucken, ob man da nicht vielleicht noch Google als automatische
Suchmaschine einstellen kann, um da noch ein bisschen das Budget zu boosten.
Ich denke, die 14,3 Millionen, die gehen dann halt an Peter Thiel und seinen
Palantir, würde ich jetzt mal so vorsichtig sagen.
Der Typ, der uns auch den J.D. Vance Vizepräsidentenkandidaten von Trump eingebrockt hat.
Die Drogendealer gefasst haben, heute diese Woche wieder hinfahren sollen.
Da hast du eine AI und die sagt, pass auf, Leute, ich habe einen ganz heißen
Tipp für euch. Gebt meinen Girl in den Zerpark.
Boah, 15,3 Millionen.
Unglaublich. Hingegangen war da auch einer. Unglaublich, diese Computer,
was sie heute alles leisten können.
Das ist echt krass.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Gut, da sind sie vielleicht nicht so gut beraten.
Vielleicht sollte man lieber auf Russland hören. Was wird die Abwehr von Cybercrime angehen?
Von dem besten Lernen.
Also ich habe dieses Cybercrime-Abkommen der UN ja nie so verfolgt.
Weil ich das irgendwie so dachte, naja, okay, das wird eh irgendwie...
Also wir haben mit Thomas natürlich hier zweimal drüber gesprochen auch schon.
Ja, natürlich, aber es ist irgendwie die UN. Ja, meine Güte.
Da wird dann irgendwie so ein Lippenbekenntnis gemacht und so.
Und sagen, wir müssen jetzt endlich mal was gegen dieses Cybercrime tun.
Aber geil ist, die Idee geht wirklich zurück auf Russland.
Also an der Stelle muss ja schon irgendwann mal einer sagen.
Leute, internationale Rechtsordnung und Russland, not a good match.
Und vor allem ausgerechnet zu Cybercrime kommt jetzt Russland und sagt,
ey, lasst uns da mal endlich was gegen tun, Leute.
Kann man super mit Problemen ablenken. Das ist schon wirklich geil,
dass Russland sagt, wir können mal ein Abkommen machen, damit das hier ein bisschen
in seine Grenzen geführt wird.
Naja, schauen wir uns dieses Abkommen mal an, wurde jetzt irgendwie ratifiziert ohne Gegenstimme.
Erstmal wird eben gesagt, warum machen wir das? Naja, wir wollen gegen Cybercrime,
Vorgehen, wir wollen die internationale Kooperation stärken und wir wollen technische
Assistenz und das Aufbauen von Kapazitäten zur Prävention.
Promoten, vereinfachen und unterstützen. Das sind also die Ziele.
Dann definieren sie erstmal ein paar Begriffe, dann sagen sie okay,
was ist denn jetzt hier der Scope?
Dann sagen sie ach ja, gar kein Problem, Prävention, Untersuchung,
Verfolgung von kriminellen Offenses und darunter Einfrieren,
Beschlagnahme, Konfiszieren und so der Gelder, die damit gemacht werden.
Und das Sammeln, Beschaffen, Aufbewahren und Teilen von Beweismitteln zum Zwecke der Strafverfolgung.
Okay, denkst du, naja, klingt ja auch erstmal irgendwie noch halbwegs okay.
Dann sagen sie, welche Offenses, also welche Verstöße wollen wir denn hier verfolgen?
Dann sagen sie, die Souveränität muss geschützt werden, die Menschenrechte müssen respektiert werden.
Okay, dann sagen wir mal, was wird denn jetzt kriminalisiert?
Ja, dann sagen sie, aha, hier illegaler Zugang,
illegales Abhören, das Interferen,
meine Güte, ich bin in diesem ganzen Bereich, spreche die ganze Zeit immer nur
Englisch, das Beeinträchtigen oder das, was ist denn Interference? Also das Beeinflussen?
Naja.
Eine Interferenz herstellen. Je nachdem, was du ausdrücken möchtest.
Also dazwischen fuchteln sozusagen.
Ja, dazwischenfurchteln, irgendwas kaputt machen. Und mit elektronischen Daten,
mit Informationen und Kommunikationstechnologie-Systemen,
der Missbrauch von Geräten, ja, da haben sie irgendwie relativ viel,
und das Fälschen von, Moment, ist damit Fälschen gemeint? Mal gucken.
Ja, genau, das Verändern und Manipulieren von Daten.
Und natürlich auch Diebstahl oder Fraud, der mithilfe von Informationssystemen begangen wird.
Und jetzt werden sich alle wundern, wie kommen wir denn bis zu Artikel 14,
ohne dass der Missbrauch von Kindern eine Rolle spielt.
Keine Sorge, auf Seite 7 von 41 geht es natürlich auch um Child Sexual Abuse
und Child Sexual Exploitation Material und allem,
was damit zu tun hat, relativ ausführlich.
Grooming kommt dann natürlich auch nochmal, kriegt seinen eigenen Artikel.
Die nichtkonsensuelle Verbreitung von intimen Bildern, Geldwäsche,
dann wer dafür auch verantwortlich ist, dann soll auch natürlich die Teilnahme
und der Versuch strafbar sein.
Und dann gibt es ein paar Limitierungen.
Aber zunächst einmal liest sich das jetzt alles erstmal so, wo du siehst, ah ja okay,
also erstmal klingt es ja alles, es geht so Abschnorchen von Daten,
Hacking und so weiter wird jetzt verboten, Kindesmissbrauch wird jetzt verboten,
ist natürlich auch in keinem Land noch erlaubt, aber okay.
Okay, ich glaube, wenn es irgendwie ein Land gibt, die haben es einfach vergessen zu verbieten.
Oder die können irgendwie in ihrem Gesetz nicht anerkennen, dass es das gibt
oder da ist Sex ohnehin verboten und das fällt dann mit da drunter oder sowas.
Aber letztendlich liest sich das ja jetzt erst mal noch halbwegs in Ordnung
und dann geht es langsam los.
Sie sagen, die elektronisch gespeicherten Daten sollen länger aufgehoben werden,
Traffic-Daten, dann sollen diese Daten irgendwie auch quasi von Personen und
von Service-Providern erfasst werden können.
Dann geht es los in den Bereich Search and Seizure of Stored Electronic Data,
also was ein Staat alles machen soll, um da reinzukommen.
Dann wird Real-Time-Echtzeitsammlung von Traffic-Data geregelt,
der Intercept von Daten,
also quasi Abfang von Daten, wie Geld, das aus Kriminalen kommt,
gesammelt werden soll. Und es geht alles so weiter.
Und wir sind jetzt erst auf Seite 16 von 41.
Und dann geht es in die internationale Kooperation.
Und Auslieferung und so weiter und so fort.
Verurteilte Personen werden ausgeliefert. Und wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut,
dass natürlich jedes Land diese Verurteilung,
Gesetze oder diese Verstöße, auf die es anwendbar wird,
anders auslegt und ein bisschen weitfassender, fragst du dich eigentlich,
ob du ein solches Abkommen wirklich mit Russland haben möchtest und ob du am
Ende, weiß ich nicht wen auch immer,
ausliefern musst oder Daten liefern musst zu diesen Personen,
die Russland gerade verfolgen möchte.
Und ob du Russland diese Konvention geben möchtest oder anderen Unrechtsländern,
um sich darauf zu berufen.
Ich denke, das ist hier, also abgesehen davon, dass das sehr weitfassend ist
und dass du sagen möchtest, es gibt hier eine internationale Kooperation.
Kooperation, zum Beispiel Artikel 43, International Cooperation for the Purpose
of Expedited Disclosure of Preserved Traffic Data.
Das heißt nichts anderes als, du hast eine internationale Kooperation,
in der du die Traffic-Daten, die du aufgezeichnet hast, zwischen den Ländern teilst.
Also so, oder? Ah, pass auf, wenn wir hier irgendwie Traffic-Daten mitgeschnitten
haben, dann haben wir jetzt eine UN-Konvention, die erleichtert,
dass wir diese Traffic-Daten weitergeben an andere Länder.
Ist mit Traffic-Daten jetzt der Traffic als solcher oder die Metadaten über den Traffic gemeint?
Schauen wir uns das mal genau an. where in the cause of the exception of a request
made pursuant to Article 42 of this Convention to preserve traffic data concerning
a specific communication,
the requested state party discovers that a service provider in another state
party was involved in the transmission of the communication the requested state
party shall expeditiously discover
agreed at
referendum also one of this article may be refused only on the basis of the
grounds contained in Article 40,
Paragraph 21b and c and Paragraph 22 of this Convention.
Also quasi diesen Traffic-Daten nicht rauszugeben, gibt es nur geringe Einschränkungen,
warum du das nicht darfst.
Aber es geht mehr, also es kann auch sich nur um Metadaten handeln,
also um sozusagen irgendwas identifizieren zu können.
Ja, also hier ist jetzt erstmal Traffic-Data ist etwas früher.
Also ich finde überhaupt erstmal, weißt du, dass du hier sagst,
du musst dich, wenn jemand aus einem anderen Land dich bittet,
Traffic-Data von einer spezifischen Kommunikation zu sammeln,
musst du das bevorzugt behandeln.
Dass es da wieder Limitationen gibt. Alles klar.
Dass man sowas überhaupt als Weltpakt hat, ist eben ein bisschen erschreckend,
wenn man sich überlegt, wie viele Länder da mit dabei sind.
Du hast ja schon, wenn du ähnliche Sachen nur auf EU-Ebene machst,
hast du irgendwie das Problem, dass da ein paar Verrückte mit dabei sind.
Und jetzt machst du das weltweit.
Mutual Legal Assistance in Accessing Stored Electronic Data.
Wir sind jetzt immer noch knapp über die Hälfte dieser Seiten.
Das ist eine sehr ausführliche Zusammenarbeit in allen Bereichen über juristische
und legislative Grenzen hinaus und das ist ein bisschen schwierig,
das mit allen Ländern dieser Erde in dieser Form so anzustreben.
Kleine Korrektur, du hast eingangs gesagt, die Länder hätten das jetzt alle
schon ratifiziert. Das haben sie natürlich noch nicht, sondern was sie getan
haben ist, sie haben das einstimmig beschlossen.
So läuft das ja bei der UN. Also es wird sozusagen erstmal in der UN mit UN-Abgesandten,
mit den Aufträgen, die halt die Regierungen haben, in der Vollversammlung abgestimmt.
Das hat jetzt stattgefunden, aber in Kraft ist das natürlich erst dann,
wenn es ratifiziert wurde und es müsste im Prinzip von jedem einzelnen Land
oder nicht nur im Prinzip, es muss von jedem einzelnen Land ratifiziert werden,
sonst ist es da auch überhaupt nicht zu irgendetwas verpflichtet.
Das ist ein Prozess, der in der Regel sehr lange dauert.
Es gibt sicherlich eine ganze Menge UN-Beschlüsse, die nie irgendwie ratifiziert wurden.
Keine Ahnung, ich habe da keinen Überblick, aber mitnichten ist es so,
dass dann alle nächste Woche sagen, super, jetzt gleich mal ratifizieren, let's go.
Sondern das ist ein sehr langer politischer Prozess und hier ist es natürlich
jetzt geboten, auf europäischer Ebene unter Umständen auch eine Ablehnung dessen
noch herbeizuführen oder zumindest auf nationaler Ebene.
Ich bin mir nicht so ganz so sicher, warum da alle so einstimmig unterwegs waren.
Also das ist schon wirklich verstörend, weil es im Prinzip so ein bisschen sagt
so, wir haben alle keinen Bock auf diese ganzen Freiheitsdiskussionen,
wir müssen doch da irgendwas tun können.
Jetzt machen wir das einfach mal auf UN-Ebene, das hat dann quasi keinerlei
unmittelbare Implikationen,
Aber das fördert dann sozusagen die Diskussion auf nationaler Ebene und wie
durch ein Wunder gibt es noch nicht mal irgendeinen Staat,
der sich auf UN-Ebene dagegen stellt,
was ich ehrlich gesagt krass finde.
Also das finde ich einfach total krass. Ich meine wir erinnern uns,
das ist ja alles überhaupt erst seit einem halben Jahr oder seit einem Jahr
überhaupt in der Diskussion, wenn ich das richtig erinnere.
Das ist ja jetzt nicht so, dass seit zehn Jahren darüber gestritten wird und
jetzt hätte man endlich mal den Punkt gefunden, sondern die haben sich da zwei,
dreimal getroffen und jetzt so, hups, ja, go.
Und das ist halt, also das Entscheidende ist hier sowas wie Verhältnismäßigkeit,
Nichtdiskriminierung, Richtervorbehalt, irgendwie solche Sachen,
die kommen einem überhaupt nicht vor.
Das heißt, du hast jetzt einfach deine lokalen Gesetze, sagst du hier übrigens,
wir verfolgen hier gerade so einen Aktivisten wegen Verdacht auf Kindesmissbrauch.
Gebt mal kurz die Daten. Wir haben doch hier ein Abkommen, dass wir das schnell kriegen.
Und das ist da nicht vorgeschrieben.
Da steht auch nicht drin, dass du als Land irgendwie prüfen musst,
ob da Menschenrechtsverstöße oder so stattfinden, sondern du musst das halt beschleunigt machen.
Also zumindest nicht im nennenswerten Ausmaß. Ja.
Naja.
Also das ist völlig überbordend, sich irgendwie dazu zu verpflichten.
Also überleg mal, auf einer anderen Seite hast du Leute, die sitzen da und machen
sich darüber Gedanken, wie sie die Kommunikation der Wirtschaft,
der Privatpersonen in irgendeiner Weise vor Spionage und sonstigem schützen.
Du machst dir darüber Gedanken, wie du russische Dissidenten und aus vielen
anderen Ländern irgendwie schützen kannst.
Und dann sagst du, nee, pass auf, wir machen am besten Pakt,
dass wir unsere Überwachungskapazitäten bevorzugt anderen Ländern zur Verfügung
stellen, wenn die einfach nur sagen, hier ist Cybercrime.
Also das ist schwierig.
Und vielleicht...
In diesem Kontext können wir direkt kurz die nächste Kurzmeldung mal machen.
Russland sperrt Signal und YouTube. Also das sind so die Leute,
mit denen du da zu tun hast.
Also bei YouTube muss ich noch die Einschränkungen machen, da bin ich mir noch
nicht ganz so sicher, wie weit das schon gediehen ist, aber es läuft gerade darauf hinaus,
also es gibt schon seit längerem Beschränkungen in der Bandbreite bei YouTube
und es wird allgemein davon ausgegangen, dass demnächst der Kanal komplett zugemacht wird.
Auf jeden Fall hat Google jetzt schon auch angekündigt, dass sie die Monetarisierung
in Russland abschalten, das heißt man kann als Russe mit YouTube eh kein Geld mehr verdienen.
Also das ist eigentlich eher ein Problem, weil YouTube noch so eine Art Outlet
ist für viele Dissidenten und teilweise eben auch für,
also auch ein Einkommen für Russen, also die jetzt mal keine Propaganda machen.
Sondern die halt einfach, was weiß ich, Musik machen und normale Dinge tun,
die Menschen manchmal so machen.
Aber YouTube ist natürlich Russland ein Dorn im Auge als Lieferant von Informationen
und dementsprechend wird das jetzt sterben.
Aber bei Signal ist es ein bisschen krasser, da ist also jetzt wirklich eine
Portsperre oder eine Hostsperre, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was sie da geblockt haben,
aber die Signal-Infrastruktur ist explizit geblockt und Signal selber ruft jetzt auch auf,
entsprechende Proxys einzurichten an anderen Stellen im Internet,
die man dann eintragen kann im Client, um weiter die Kommunikation über Signal zu ermöglichen.
Also Signal hat Support für einen einfachen TLS-Proxy und da musst du einfach Signal Settings,
Privacy Advanced und dann Censorship Circumvention und da musst du halt irgendwie
mal so ein paar Proxys in die Welt setzen, die Anleitung in den,
den Shownotes.
Also dann kopiere ich da jetzt direkt rein.
Okay, und dann hat noch jemand eine schöne Webseite gemacht.
Wir haben hier schon relativ oft über die CUI gesprochen, die Clearingstelle
Urheberrecht im Internet.
Eine private Organisation, die Webseitensperren vereinbart und homogenisiert
nach der Einschätzung, dass diese gegen das Urheberrecht verstoßen würden und
zwar ohne richterliche Beschlüsse.
Und dann machen die Internetanbieter sagen, ja super geil, dann machen wir hier
mal so eine Netzsperre, einfach so.
Und da gibt es jetzt eine Webseite, die alle gesperrten Domains sammelt und veröffentlicht.
Das ist sehr interessant, weil man dann eben sich anschauen kann,
wo es vielleicht noch interessante Dinge im Internet gibt.
Zum Beispiel kann ich dank dieser Seite jetzt bald wieder waterpolo.jokerguide.com besuchen.
Ich glaube, ich habe keinen gesperrten DNS-Server, aber da kann ich also Livestreamings
von Waterpolo endlich wieder gucken. Ein Sport, der viel zu wenig Beachtung findet.
Und da sind also diese ganzen Domains aufgelistet. Da wird dann erklärt,
wie man quasi diese Sperren umgehen kann.
Und finde ich mal ganz interessant so als Inspiration.
Ja, ist von so einem jungen Entwickler zusammengetragen worden,
die Liste, der sonst Minecraft-Server-Seeker betreibt.
Auch gut.
Auch das muss gefunden werden im Internet.
Alright. Damit sind wir, ach wir haben noch gar nicht über LMP500 gesprochen.
Ja, aber jetzt kommen ja die Termine.
Weil wir die ganze Zeit davon sprechen.
Vielleicht sollten wir erstmal auf die andere Veranstaltung hinweisen,
weil die ist quasi jetzt übermorgen.
Hatten wir gar nicht hier in der Liste. Ich weiß nicht warum.
Die denken wohl, sie kommen ja ohne eine Ankündigung bei LMP aus. Die FrostCon.
Die für Free Software, Open Source, alles mögliche schon seit sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr vielen Jahren unterwegs ist.
Das Ganze in Siegburg, bei Bonn.
Da könnt ihr hingehen.
In St.
Augustin.
Ach ja, genau. Das ist da so dieses Dreieck.
Und habe ich Siegburg gesagt, jetzt muss ich mich mal hier vergegenwärtigen,
dass ich keinen Unsinn erzähle. Ja, St.
Augustin, genau. Das ist genau zwischen Bonn und Siegburg sozusagen.
Und ja, und wir haben auch noch eine Veranstaltung.
Wie ihr wisst, Logbuch und Heißpolitik 500 und wir gehen jetzt hier so langsam ins Finale.
Also T-Shirts könnt ihr jetzt keine mehr bestellen. Das war's.
Genau, weil wir haben jetzt die T-Shirts bestellt.
Genau, haben wir gemacht.
Die werden jetzt produziert und vielleicht schon mal für diejenigen,
für die vielen, über die Hälfte der Leute haben auch noch ein T-Shirt bestellt, ähm,
Da bekommt ihr dann ebenfalls so ein Ticket für.
Also das ist auch ein QR-Code, den ihr dann einfach an der Ausgabestelle den
freundlichen Mitarbeitern hinhaltet und dann wird euch das Shirt gegeben und
das ist natürlich schon vor der Veranstaltung möglich, deswegen machen wir zwei Stunden vorher auf.
17 Uhr geht's schon los da. und dann könnt ihr da alle im Einheitslook rumsitzen
Ja, kommt ja einfach Das wäre eigentlich ganz nett, so eine freie Oberkörperschlange,
Und dann sagen wir No Shirt, No Service Also sei vorsichtig.
Was du dir da wünschst, auf jeden Fall wichtig, dass du auseinander zeigst,
also ein QR-Code fürs reingehen, einer fürs fürs Shirt.
Und ja genau, 17 Uhr macht der Laden auf.
Es gibt dort eine Bar, es gibt dort Sitzgelegenheiten, es gibt da ein ausgedehntes
Foyer und wir haben das halt so gemacht, damit ihr die Möglichkeit habt, dort anzukommen.
Es gibt auch eine Garderobe und dann könnt ihr entspannt euch mit allen anderen
Hörerinnen und Hörern und soweit auch mit uns, wenn wir da die Zeit finden, da schon rumzugondeln,
interagieren genau und dann 19 uhr wollen wir dann loslegen,
Und dann erfahrt ihr endlich, wenn wir da eingeladen haben. Weil das sagen wir voll nicht.
Naja, aber wir sind ganz zufrieden mit der Auswahl. So wie kann ich schon mal...
Hervorragende Auswahl.
Ja.
Hervorragend.
Ja, loben wir uns noch ein bisschen selber. Richtig froh.
Richtig happy.
Gut.
498 ist Ist in der Dose, wie der Amerikaner sagt.
Sagt der Amerikaner in der Dose?
Ist in the can, sagt er natürlich.
Ach so.
Finde ich eigentlich einen schönen Ausdruck, dass man das so eingedost hat.
Was sagen wir? Eingetütet. Wir tüten das.
Eingetütet, wir tüten. Ja, aber das machen die Amerikaner auch.
Aber sie sagen es nicht.
Ja, sie sagen.
Ich finde, eine Dose hat schon.
Dose, zivilisatorische Errungenschaft.
Ja, absolut. Kulturgut. Vor allem bewährt sich.
Also was haben wir nicht schon alles erfunden, wo wir dann 20 Jahre später gesagt
haben, das war jetzt nicht so eine gute Idee.
Aber Dose war eine gute Idee oder was? Klar.
Also Weißblechdosen funktionieren immer noch super, sind immer noch kein Gesundheitsrisiko,
halten Essen günstig lange am Leben.
Also kannst du wunderbar recyceln, ist ein Top-Produkt. Also gegen Weißblechdosen
kann man wirklich mal gar nichts sagen.
Oder, also ich meine.
Da fällt mir einiges ein, was nicht so geil ist.
Das ist also so Dosen und Podcast, also da geht fast nichts drüber.
Podcast eigentlich auch gut recyceln, aber jetzt sind die eigentlich auch immer das Gleiche.
Nein.
Vor allem nicht am 31.8. in der Urania in Berlin mit herausragenden Gästen.
Genauso ist es wie die Subscribe 11, die hat auch herausragende Gäste.
Nein, es kommt auch nicht schon wieder Subscribe 11. Nee. Wann ist das?
Über das Podcast.
LMP 501 hat übrigens auch herausragenden Gäste.
Jetzt mach doch nicht immer so viel Versprechungen.
Ist aber so.
Promiseless Deliver More. Also das ist mein...
Mach ich ja schon. Ich sag ja nur, es gibt herausragende Gäste.
Das ist einfach schlimm mit dir.
So, schönen Abend euch noch.
Genau, bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.